[Música]
en un mundo más globalizado que cada día
sufren las consecuencias de nuestra
huella ambiental las redes sociales se
han convertido en una herramienta para
varios activistas por el clima que
trabajan para crear conciencia sobre
cómo nuestras acciones afectan de manera
positiva negativa todo nuestro entorno
en directo américa nos preocupamos por
nuestro planeta y apoyamos estas
iniciativas que impactan positivamente a
los jóvenes y a toda nuestra sociedad
hoy nos enfocamos en el reciclaje las
toneladas de basura que diariamente
nosotros generamos sobre todo los
plásticos que tanto contaminan nuestros
océanos y que se encuentran hasta en
nuestra sangre convertidos en
microplásticos esto según los estudios
recientes y para ello entonces quiero
saludar en este momento a una invitada
de lujo que tenemos en nuestro estudio
de directo américa de france24 ella es
marcela recicladora marsé gracias por
estar con nosotros en directo américa
muy buenos días buenos dias hola mis
recicladores de siempre saludo así hola
me reciclamos como estas amarse como le
ha ido bien feliz de estar acá hablar de
reciclaje
ese mensaje pues a cada vez más personas
marzo se estaba que estamos en una
cadena internacional expliqué el
entonces a todo nuestro público de
américa latina y todos los países que
nos ven que son los recicladores en
colombia con la importancia de ellos en
nuestra sociedad bueno yo les cuento que
en colombia algunos países de
latinoamérica como ecuador perú y bueno
hay otros donde existen los recicladores
yo les digo recicla amores que son las
personas que nos dedicamos a recoger
reciclaje entonces ustedes nos ven en
carretas que son como nuestros carritos
donde llevamos el reciclaje y vamos
metiendo la mano a la basura y sacando
las botellas dos los papeles cartones
vidrio aluminio todo lo que nos sirve
para reciclar y pues esa nuestra fuente
está marsé y cómo nació esta idea de ser
una youtuber recicladora con de donde le
vino esa idea usted bueno pues hay
youtuber de todo no de bailes de comida
de deportes de todo y de reciclaje no
había entonces yo dije no pues toca
ponerme la 10 y empezar a enseñar a la
gente a reciclar pero desde la
perspectiva del reciclamos
es como les digo lame el mejor profesor
de reciclar es un reciclamos que es el
que mete la mano que se recicla more
exacto explíquenos lo mejor que es un
reciclador a diferencia de una empresa
de reciclaje es digamos exactamente el
recicla more es el oficio informal si me
entiendes desde ese oficio que que uno
está en la calle digamos las empresas de
reciclaje lo que hacen es transformar
por decirlo así todas esas botellas
todos esos pero el recicla more es el
que recoge el que tiene hemos dicho la
mano negra como ha sido marc se el
impacto que ha tenido en las redes
sociales es su labor y además y qué tan
buen trabajo ha hecho medido en las
redes sociales en sus seguidores y pues
la gente en la calle que le dice cuando
la ve pues cuando yo empecé yo realmente
no pensé que me fueran a seguir yo y
bueno pues sí me de mi mamá y mis amigos
bacán y de repente empezó a crecer y la
gente marche que bacano porque es que yo
enseño de una manera r re fácil re
bacano divertida dirían en otros lugares
y re diferente entonces empezó a crecer
a crecer y la gente me empezó a
preguntar más que son de lo botó que el
papel que hago con esto que sí sucia me
empecé a convertir en la google del
reciclaje sin querer queriendo y yo de
repente salí a la calle la gente marsé
que una foto y yo como si la gente me
conoce y empezó hacía crecer y pues yo
feliz de ser la profesora del reciclaje
es decir que que es lo más importante
usted como profesora del reciclaje que
le diría a una persona por ejemplo que
no recicla en ese momento que se anima a
reciclar y cómo hacerlos a que tan
fáciles porque pues no es una tarea
difícil tampoco no marzo no yo siento
que la gente lo ve como algo difícil y
si como pero eso tanta caneca tanto
color sea como que no lo entienden
todavía pero yo creo que una vez usted
dice bueno es que esto a ayudar a salvar
muchas cosas de nuestro planeta no le
digo que lo único pero si va a ayudar
muchísimo entonces es cuestión de
deberse mis vídeos y entender que no es
tan difícil como parece y que realmente
es una responsabilidad de todos porque
no es un favor hay gente que dice no yo
te estoy ayudando no es que no es para
mí el favor mi amor es que quien es el
que yo en el planeta usted o yo pues
todos entonces hagámoslo juntos a ver
marte también en una ciudad como bogotá
pongamos el ejemplo como una américa
latina' del 100% de la basura que todos
los habitantes de una ciudad
latinoamericana generamos cuanto se
recicla yo imagino que nos podemos
impresionar del porcentaje tan bajo no
marcela si bueno por lo menos en bogotá
digamos generamos 6 mil 300 toneladas de
basura diarias de eso más o menos
estamos en un porcentaje entre el 15 al
17 por ciento entonces realmente no
estamos tan mal hay lugares donde está
peor si digamos por ejemplo brasil está
una tacita muy bajita de reciclaje pero
la idea es pues impregnarnos todos como
latinoamérica como américa como planeta
y entender que es que es una labor que
debemos hacer sin importar seguimos en
colombia en ecuador en perú porque hay
gente que dice no yo en europa si
reciclo en colombia no no eso en donde
quiera que usted vaya haga lo además la
doble moral de nosotros latinoamericanos
como usted lo dijo yo en europa reciclo
en un país desarrollado nos en eeuu o en
otro país que hay si me multan pues aquí
no porque no me multan no tengo el
castigo realmente generar esa conciencia
imagino que usted es lo que quiere crear
a través de su contenido las redes
sociales para que la gente lo haga por
voluntad por mí no tener un policía y
siempre diciéndole lo que tiene que
hacer marsé es que yo creo que la multa
no la está cobrando el planeta o sea
cuando tú es que cada vez el mar está
más arriba que cada vez hay más
calentamiento global esa es la peor
multa yo prefiero que mejore en agua que
ya que realmente no tenga cómo vivir es
así marsé y cómo subir eso porque ese
porcentaje de reciclaje en nuestras
ciudades latinoamericanas como subirla
bueno primero entender que no es difícil
que es fácil y que usted se ponga a
pensar bueno el instinto es que todo que
hace por un lado a meter el reciclaje
que son plásticos papel cartón vidrio
aluminio tetra pak chatarra que son
todas estas cositas plateadas que tienen
en la casa en todo la y lo van a poner
una caneca parte de los residuos
orgánicos que ojalá lo usemos para el
compostaje y ya en otro lado la basura
que es lo que se va al relleno sanitario
entonces empezar a tener esa conciencia
de la separación en países
latinoamericanos si nos toca conocer a
nuestro reciclamos porque es esa persona
que se va a llevar el reciclaje entonces
yo sé que a veces dice uno pero como lo
conoce y él está en la calle como conoce
a cualquier persona hola cómo estás cómo
te ha ido tú qué días pasas y así ya se
hace todo más fácil o hablar con el
administrador del conjunto para los que
vienen edificio y hacer la labor de
bueno realmente me voy a proponer que me
reciclaje llegué a las manos del
reciclamos mar sé cuál es la situación
de ustedes los recicladores en las
calles de bogotá digamos bueno la verdad
hay mucha inseguridad no como como en
todo pues no está expuesto a que lo
roben uno pues a veces anda sin uniforme
entonces puede que lo estrelló un carro
que uno no tiene pues el reflectivo ese
ahí pues mucha mucha también digamos
delincuencia y la verdad es es un
trabajo que tiene demasiado riesgos y
uno no tiene aire el entonces es es
triste ya es triste porque cada vez se
ve que el reciclador dice no yo prefiero
trabajar en otra cosa digamos que hoy en
día no es un trabajo regulado por
ejemplo aquí en colombia en la idea
estamos pasando por un proceso donde ya
hay un tiempo para que lo reciclamos y
nos volvamos a empresas de aseos y por
decirlo así empresas que prestan el
servicio pero también eso es difícil
porque a dime como tú le dices a una
persona que lleva todo el día trabajando
en la calle todos estos años y el
analista monte empresa neta contador
entonces estamos en ese proceso y
poquito a poquito pero en la idea que
este trabajo sea algo formal como
cualquier otro tiene que ser tiene que
ser así y marc sé hasta dónde quiere
llegar usted con sus redes sociales qué
impacto real quiere generar digamos que
usted diga el día de mañana ya puedo
cerrar las redes sociales porque ya hice
mi trabajo descifrado digamos que casi
que nunca se va a caer pero la meta más
grande que tiene usted a corto plazo
bueno me encantaría de verdad llegar a
todos los países pues no sólo también el
inglés pero me encantaría poder ser esa
profe el reciclaje no sólo para colombia
sino para muchos lugares poder conectar
con otros países en este momento estoy
trabajando en un cuento para niños
entonces no feliz con todos los
proyectos que enseñen y que dejen algo
para desde el mar se extrae una muy
buena comunicadora limitó entonces que
se pare un momento y despide el programa
que no venga a marcel entonces
despedimos este programa directo américa
pongas aquí yo soy bajito y tengo mitad
y mitad acá al aquí quedamos los dos
entonces usted quiere empezar le estoy
yo terminar la la terminal hizo istomin
o bueno y entonces de esta manera
llegamos al final como siempre en este
programa directo américa de france 24
para mí como siempre ha sido un gusto
acompañarnos el día de hoy marsé que les
vaya muy bien que me sigan en todas las
redes sociales y no se espía de no se
despeguen perdón de brass 24 muchas
gracias y como siempre el minuto en el
noticiero habitual ahí lo es pero ya a
sumarse más de gracias gracias a ustedes